I play myself in the past present and
the future it starts in the future and
in the film ends with me coming out my
mother's vagina which camera height lad
by a book
well you're not LED Bible you're just
people watching it but we're caught and
here to give you some life advice
dominant Michael oh it's my name's
birthday and she's not so traditional
what should I get her Rosa North London
a neighbor X hmm or a night for but if
she's very not traditional I don't want
any advice but I'm a massive broke Ford
FC fan who do you think will make the
playoffs and who's your favorite player
pull from sorry I'll take this mm-hmm I
don't really like football Paul I just
started a kit no we don't really know my
god my best mates and I keep getting
arguments around music genres getting
arguments I'm all about Gary's but he
thinks house is the thing what can I say
to shut him up for once and all Tim from
Brixton Tim just what I think a house
punch him in his face
if you won't find this in the garage
scene what would you be doing with your
lives
Laura Hackney Luca Luca like naked
I'd probably work in and Fela megabowl I
would be blazing probably directing my
own film by now agency grind of the
movie it's I play myself in the past
present and the future it starts in the
future and in the film ends with me
coming out my mother's vagina dripping
and probably set in Dubai because most
things are moving today it's the next
global superpower people say I'm
arrogant but I think I'm just being
honest how did how to change my vibe
we start really from Islington you've
written how do I change my vibe never
change your vibe because I'm also
arrogant people say but really it's just
I know I'm the best so in fact that
means I'm the most humble person you
would ever meet people say I'm hot but
unapproachable
you can
I think I always put out nice vibes how
do I make men see the real me Remy from
South London I'll have to take this I'm
Remy although it's not men that try to
approach me it's women usually but they
never say they do because they're too
intimidated by me and my beauty and my
green eyes yourself exactly what I would
say remedy is just God's people and say
I'm up for having sex if you are sun
cycle don't play games yeah exactly just
went up Tron was like to have sex
mmm she said you think about it he did
that every night we went out yeah yeah a
year ago got Rocha eventually wanted to
break ground yeah yeah yeah yeah North
average in it
exactly Laura average exactly so high
lad but I know that's it klutz FM
advising the [ __ ] out you parental
advisory advice advise it
[Music]